all right Heather hi Heather where you
from originally I'm from Texas what part
um Tyler Texas is East close to Dallas
tell me about your family growing up
both of my parents were
alcoholics they used to try to beat each
other all the time and got taken away by
CPS so we kind of lived with relatives
for a
while
um then we went back to
I went back to my mom with my older
sister and two of my sisters stayed with
relatives so I don't really know
them
um I don't know how would you describe
your childhood in general uh it was
really chaotic all the time my mom was
always trying to kill herself or I don't
know run away or disappear I don't crazy
stuff it makes it hard for a kid yeah
yeah what kind of girl were you in high
school I didn't go to high school um I
was put in a
juvenile
prison for 27 months and in Texas if
you're um incarcerated you can get your
GED at 16 and so I did that they told me
I could still go to school and get my
diploma but whenever I tried to they
told me I was a waste of taxpayers money
so I never got to go to high school
really what have you done with your life
since school or since
that well I was um I was a housewife for
13 years um you have kids I have two
sons I had a daughter but um she she was
accidentally run over in our driveway at
2 and passed away so now I have two sons
sorry that's okay um how did that
happen my
stepmother um was looking in the glove
box when she was backing out of the
driveway and my daughter wanted to go
with her and ran out and fell and the
back tires got her
head so sorry it's
okay so I have two sons that are 12 and
13 they live in Texas right now
now
um and drugs started for you at some
point um I started doing drugs when I
was 12 well I guess 11 11 I smoked weed
and then at 12 by 12 I was smoking crack
my boyfriend at the time was 21 he was a
lot older so that's what he did so your
boyfriend was 21 you were whole
12 um
after that boyfriend I had a boyfriend
that was 25 he was in the
cartel um he used to pimp us
out I would bring like my friends from
school and get them on drugs and help
get them pimped
out that was my job I
guess when I was with him so you were
working as a prostitute but you're also
recruiting
yes which I feel awful about
now and drugs are getting the girls yeah
into it keeping them into it yeah but
drug what drug was that oh usually
crack how long were you in Texas doing
that oh that was just like a year or two
then that's when I went to juvenile
prison so that's how I got away from the
cartel and that whole thing you went to
prison for that no I went to prison for
um run away resisting arrest minor
possession of alcohol minor possession
of
Narcotics
um I think that's it
maybe oh and Grand Theft
bottle I was supposed to at in Texas you
have a minimum link stay and you can
stay longer based on your behavior I had
a minimum length day of 9 months and I
stayed 27
months for behavior that
sucks and you got married after that I
have never been married we were just
together I say a housewife live you had
kids after that I had kids I had my
first kid when I was
21 how old do you know I'm
35 what made you decide to come out here
to California um I came with my
children's father um we lived in Texas
for 10 years he was tired of it he's
from vanai so he wanted to come home so
we came and we moved to
chadsworth um with the kids with the
kids and
then I just got sick of him
being him controlling and selfish and
whatever so I just left home and went to
Venice and became homeless in Venice for
a few
months and you've been on the streets
ever since no um I stayed in Venice for
four months I went to jail for robbery
first degree burglary and a
GTA and after that I was put on a mental
health diversion I was sentenced to two
years program so of until a month ago I
was in program I had 3 months left to
finish but I kept getting high so the
eth time I got high program they told me
I needed to leave
until I could um pee clean which should
have been 3 days but it's been a little
over a month almost two months I
think
so
yeah your drug now is what I do I do
um mess mostly crack
occasionally I smoke a ton of
weed how long you've been on Skid Row
I've been on Skid Row for almost a
month um see I was falling asleep on the
bus and wherever I woke up I was safe
for a couple days I've been to Englewood
Compton wads West LA East LA but I met
this guy in West LA that was like you
want to come ride with me I have some
baggage bags in
storage I skid roll I'm just going to
grab them and we're going to come back
to West Hollywood well we got here and
he does fit all so he kept nodding out
and after like 6 hours of trying to get
him to wake up I was like I have to get
money and I have to get cigarettes so I
had to leave them there and I've been
wanding around skid R ever
since skid R is right no yeah it
is been here a month been raped six
times already been held hostage and I
can't tell you how many
tents how are you making
money uh I prostitut a little not very
often usually I'm just
broke do you go to the shelters for food
or so I have really bad social anxiety
so I can't stand in line without getting
really dizzy and Shak and throwing up so
I just kind of go hungry most of the
time which really sucks I should get
over it but I I've been that way my
whole
life is that from the childhood with
your alcoholic parents do you think
probably and we had to hide like all the
trauma in our lives so we were always
alone my sisters
were two twin sisters that were seven
years older than me and one that was
five so they didn't really hang out with
me cuz they were so much older
so I was always by
myself so being around people I'm really
like socially
do you sleep down here um I
sleep every once in a while um you don't
have a tent or anything like that don't
have a tent um I have a few friends that
I can go to their tent and sleep for a
couple hours but mostly I just walk I
walk all night because it's dangerous to
sleep
and if you sit down you not off because
you're so tired so it's just easier just
to Walk and Walk and Walk how many days
do you stay up in a row uh four or five
until I start
hallucinating and then I'll try to go to
sleep then you sleep hard for a day or
so no I sleep for a few hours that's it
one day I slept for 10 hours but usually
I only sleep for a
few I'm light sleeper and I am very
paranoid so it's hard to being asleep
for a long time with all the sirens down
here it's impossible to sleep
yeah I wasn't paranoid like this till I
got
here after like the first week of being
here I've gotten very weird about a lot
of stuff like trying to figure out what
the setup is what the plot is all the
time what is the alterior motive
constantly in my head like trying to
figure it out out what this person is
trying to do to me do you think using
crystal meth and
then um not sleeping for 5 days might
I'm sure it makes it worse it's got to
make it worse but I don't
know I feel I have good reason to be
paranoid like something Spilled Out
somebody gave me a bottle of what was
supposed to be nail polish it spilled
out in my backpack I didn't know it and
so I used my brush was made to get all
of my hair was made to get all over my
face and nobody believed me they said I
was
tweaking and um it was glue like clear
glue all over my face I finally went to
the clinic because I thought I was going
insane and they said I did have glue on
my face just weird stuff like that like
who does that to somebody I don't know
what's the worst thing that's happened
to you living on the streets I got
slapped and kicked in the face and told
to leave or I'd get shot that was kind
of scary that was probably the worst
thing because a lot of people have held
me hostage and been scary but not
actually hit me or anything you know do
you have any family or friends that you
can go to if you I have no one in
California period and my mom's dead my
dad's dead one of my sisters is dead so
I have two sisters left but they didn't
grow up with me they grew up when we got
by CPS they decided to stay with
relatives and so um I don't really know
them we text each other hey how you
doing every once in a while but that's
about it so besides my kids it's just
me do you think the drug use causes your
social anxiety or the social anxiety
makes you use the
drugs um the social anxiety makes me use
the drugs you had these problems when
you were younger I've had it my whole
life as long as I remember since I was
little little like if I'm not on drugs
I'm basically mute like I don't talk at
all really yeah but I also or whatever
reason since my daughter died um if I
don't do drugs I'll sleep for 18 20
hours a day for four or 5 days in a row
like have no life just
sleep oh lately I've been getting
drugged I don't know what with is not in
the drugs cuz the last couple of nights
I haven't been doing drugs because I've
been scared getting drugged it's in the
food people are giving me like two
nights in a row somebody gave me
something to eat and then all of a
sudden I got dizzy and started
hallucinating like crazy like that bugs
are on me and hands were coming through
the tent
and and then just knocking
out but I don't know what they're
drugging me with it's weird I'm still
kind of messed up like it feels like I'm
on a boat everything is just rocking
do you have any any good memories of
your childhood or of in your life yeah
like Christmas and
so what's your biggest fear
now dying and being dying here and just
being remembered as like a drug wh and
not a person
that's probably my biggest fear I don't
mind dying here but I don't want to be
remembered like
that what's your biggest
regret
uh probably leaving home leaving my my
children's
father well not really leaving him
leaving my kids I just walked out on my
kids
which is crazy because I was with my
kids 24 hours a day until they went to
daycare and then PCA soccer mom I was
with my kids constantly and then I just
just disappeared I imagine losing your
daughter the way you did must have been
a terrible setback yeah it was I pretty
much lost my mind that's when I started
doing MTH I was like
I've never been the same
since I got in do drugs when I was with
my children's father that whole 13 years
that's a lot I did a couple of times but
it' be like one night you know what I
mean wasn't like on
drugs
you think you're a little bit
self-destructive a little what
self-destructive definitely even here
like I'll get a friend somebody that
actually cares about me and completely
sabotage
it for absolutely no reason have you
been in love
before uh
yeah it wasn't really reciprocated on
the same
level I was always like not good
enough what would you say is your
greatest
strength um it's weird I have this
disorder I don't know if it' be a
strength but it gets me to the day I
have a disorder where something bad
happens to me in like a few hours or the
next day it's it's not real anymore it's
like it happened to somebody else so I
can get over it like that it's
interesting so like where other people
would be so traumatized over being raped
to me it's like it happened to her I
watched it you know what I mean it's
hard to explain you disassociate people
think I'm just a psycho or a liar that
make it up one of the
two you feel like you're misunderstood
by most people definitely
I'm a really weird
person do you feel like life is
unfair H not really not really I feel
like it's what you make
it I choose to be here I could be in
program I could be in a
shelter I could probably be in SRO but I
like outside and I like to be free
and nobody understands that I think I'm
I'm the dumbest person in the world you
prefer to be on the street I do and not
going to getting clean in a program
Y and it's not even about the drugs it's
just I don't
know it's just being
free nobody expects anything homeless
people there's no standard there there's
just no pressure yeah responsibility
mhm and then there's a lot of horrible
people out here but there's a lot of
really good ones
too and I feel like they deserve
somebody to be around to be nice to them
to help them
out and that person should be
me what's your favorite memory from your
life my life
[Music]
um when my first son was born there's
just nothing like that first baby you
know not just the others AR that sounds
bad are you concerned that you're not
there for your children
um well yes and no like before I got
here I I'm not around my kids I talked
to them three four times a
week um we're really close we talk about
everything but I was so disappointed in
myself about leaving program I haven't
called them in this entire month and a
half two months and now I just keep
putting it off and I'll get a phone and
I'll be like I want to call them and
it'll get stolen I
lost that's an excuse I'm just
procrastinating cuz then on they're
going to be really
upset is this your lowest point right
now I don't feel like I'm that
low I'm making it you're okay yeah I'm
okay Heather what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your
life
um Gangsters Don't Have Feelings
gangsters don't have feelings yeah
that's what keeps me going every day
just remind myself of that we don't have
feelings all right Heather thank you so
much for sharing your story M hope
you're safe out here thank you thank you
very
much